When you look around these days,
it's easy to forget the mobile
revolution is really a few years old.
Smartphones were becoming popular
in the US by 2003, 2004 and
even earlier in Japan.
But, it wasn't really until 2007 when
Apple released the iPhone that mobile
apps became a thing.
Now, it's hard to imaging
life without them.
They fundamentally changed how we
communicate with each other and
how we interact with everything
from banks to newspapers to taxis
to your neighborhood pizza boy.
And, they've created a whole
new way to play games.
Over the last decade, mobile gaming
has grown into a huge market.
Developers have embraced it and
mobile game popularity has exploded
along with the new platforms.
At first, writing games for phones or
a tablet was much harder than for PCs or
gaming consoles.
The hardware was there but gaming
libraries and tools hadn't caught up.
Today, all the pieces are there.
Powerful hardware with stunning
graphics and audio capabilities.
Tools and frameworks to enable fast and
easy game development.
Widely accepted monetization options to
support many different business models.
And most importantly,
a world-wide base of customers who love
to play games on their mobile devices.
It's an amazing time to
learn game development.